[Music] citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Teran this guy Andrew flash cord I got Halloween
nails and a Halloween shirt on but we're not
watching a Halloween movie Are We nope sure not
21 Jump Street I wish that you would have jumped
and then I could show a street we can't do that
here we can't we can't we just don't have time
listen you guys got to leave a like even though
this intro it's lacking you got to leave a comment
you got say listen terara get with it be better I
agree okay and you also have to ring the bell ring
the bell thanks to prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights and if you haven't joined
patreon we call you super sexy over there so get
over there now you can sneak up with your own copy
and also don't forget that Greg and John offer
exclusive highlights and watch alongs over there
on the patreon or we also call you again I'll say
it super sexy we're in it now I think I'm ready
are you ready to watch 21 Jump Street let's do
it may I have your pleas may I have your
ATT please I feel like this song was also
released in 2005 and this is the Year 2005
probably like right I feel like probably
I don't know music like I know films but
you're probably right I think it was around
there
oh the braces known each other for a really long
time and uh live across the street from each other
and stuff and uh me on every first date you're
not asking me to prom are youh [__] no no I I
I I don't know how to put this nicely I that was
nice I thought just straight to the point yeah
I've heard way worse to me right if you didn't
get your grades up you weren't going to the prom
but I'm I'm going to be prom King I'm glad you
had a great time in school cuz you ain't learned
nothing at least you remembered at prom there's
a king I mean that he did learn something yeah
and he learned how to kick a trash can I yeah he's
doing all right yeah is he going to pick it up oh
ow you can't teach that in acting how to no how
to kick a trash kick a trash can like awkwardly
like that only Jonah Hill could pull that off oh
we meet again Slim Shady what's up holy [__] how
do you recognize him without his braces just cuz
he still looks nerdy he just he just screams nerd
such [__] dang is he going to help him study and
he's going to help him do the physical stuff oh
100a yeah he's got the brains and he's got the the
Hot Tots [Music] has I would love to be a person
on one of those popups for the training academy
I just think it'd be fun maybe get my name out
there a little bit more hey see Min is improved
that's it's all about improvements I present to
you the graduates of class 137 you're ready for
a lifetime of being badass mother yeah heck yeah
that was a lot faster than I was expecting to
be with the get right in there yeah they're
like that's great set you up for that you guys
really think there a police matter to get your
frisbee back get your own [__] frisbee oh
[__] yours isn't loaded right huh no we're
supposed to unload him first right you no
that's that's no fun come on this guy like
big time drug dealers if we could take them
down as our first bus we'd be off Park Duty
for sure you see what I see Cannabis sativa
all right this is how you know was at least
10 15 years ago cuz right now this would not be
a big deal at all in fact the cops be like can
we can we take a few pups have we forgotten
that the use of marijuana is illegal man you
guys even real cops you look like the kids on
the Halloween is called M EA that is my dream
to eat straight up peanut butter with a fork oh
damn what I chase someone Chase someone are you
leaving your bike here all right on the bike it's
classic I'm going shoot you if you don't slow down
man come on the editing this really helps to
play with like the the bait and like the punch
line it's great it's going to say dude you're
probably faster without the bike that's it come
here damn it's going to charge you dude
you got to read a Miranda rights problem
is if you don't read Miranda rights you you
can't arrest them yeah these guys are not by
the book [__] oh boy as we can see stated
right there the department was forced to drop
the charges because you forgot to read him his
Miranda right ah you called it I'm not even a
cop I knew that yeah that's the basic thing
do you even know the Miranda recognize that
actor oh yeah I mean Bill Last of Us oh yeah of
course but also um so many other things oh yeah
yeah go ahead it's four declamatory sentences
followed by a question for a total of 57 words
it it I think it sounds something like uh you
are under arrest you have the right to remain
silent you oh right you have the right to remain
an attorney did you say that you have the right
to be an attorney you do have the right to be
an attorney if you want to where were you I was
chasing my Pur honestly he did get away that my
elbow yeah we're Reviving a canceled under under
cover police program from the 80s and revamping
it for modern times so all they do now is recycle
[__] from the past and expect us all not to
notice these programs involves the use of young
immature seing officers you're going to send us
into like a child sex slavery ring or something
whoa that's heavy and deep yeah that's great uh
where should we report to down on Jump Street
37 Jump Street 37 37 right oh it's 21 I think
it's uh you under arrest you have the right
for anything you say can will be used against
you in a court of law you have the right to an
attorney you cannot afford an attorney one
will be one will be given to you thank you
RoboCop all the old Misfits in a church hey it
the cube cool I didn't know he's in this get
your mothering ass up when I'm talking you will
be going undercover as high school students hey
cool this is giving me a Never Been Kissed
Vibe yeah cops edition Justus Beaver Molly
Cyrus looking [__] angry black Captain it ain't
nothing but a stupid stereotype I'm black and I
work my ass off to be the captain and sometimes I
get angry so suck a embrace your stereotypes like
this guy right here handsome and he's probably a
dummy he's short and insecure and he's probably
good with money oh you are good with money
do not have sexual relations with students
or teachers sir you hear that that's you don't
do it man I'd be more I'd be more worried about
Jonah Hill doing it honestly cuz he's the one
who didn't get the girls in high school right
clearly I wasn't talking to you big when
I say shut the [__] up I'm talking to
you cheers the new synthetic drug goes
by the street name HFS is this a a drug
Jessica will you go to prom with me
but I already know the answer it's
yes this is great where can I where can I get
this drug yeah exactly sign me up I want to do
this man this kid rules ruled let me guess he
passed away found in his room no okay I don't
want to do it anymore jeno I enrolled you in
a bunch of [__] courses like photography
and drama since you were a virgin through
High School it says that I just assumed
it here's your new identities all right Brad
and Doug McQuade Doug McQuade that's so close to
Total Recall Doug Quaid Arnold Schwarzenegger's
character find the supplier first we don't have
to worry about the dealer God damn trate the
dealers find a supplier got it sounds simple
straight forward I'm sure they'll do it on day
one and we won't have an entire film out of it
hey Korean Jesus I know we haven't made our first
arrest or maybe I'm not the best cop Ken Jesus I
just really don't want to [__] this up sorry for
swearing so much the end I I don't really know how
to end a prayer the end that's great you two are
staying at Schmid's parents house for the duration
of this assignment oh no oh God guys can we can
we get rid of this stuff I mean it looks like I
died in the car crash and you guys haven't moved
on that's so great I look like Fred Savage from
The Wonder Years he he really really does he does
am I even wearing underwear in this picture um why
I remember you know why told it to a therapist
about 8,000 times oh my God oh my God he really
does look like Fred Savage from the Wonder year
yeah I love Fred Savage so much he probably got
told that so many times as a kid yeah and probably
just put that into an improv improv joke yeah you
got to study this stuff forget those identities
they're [__] you know back in the day you were
super popular and I wasn't one man three balls
I think that's awesome that's great come on man
we're adults now we're best bu it's definitely
not going to happen again I'm predicting Jonah
Hill going to get the beautiful woman for the
prom I'm calling it although that's kind of
creepy cuz he's much older now yeah you say can
and will be used against you int of law you the
right to an attorney you cannot afford attorney
one will be appointed there you go you had it
you guys should have known this going to say you
should have known this way before don't try hard
at anything I do that every day if anyone steps
you on the first day of school you punch them
directly in the face five drive a kickass car
I really fail on all the other ones though oh
they went to the police impound sick dope that's
a sweet Camaro my guess is that car was from the
original TV show just going to take a guess
I have no idea but awesome it's probably an
Easter egg I don't know yeah just guessing I have
no idea that is a cool ass car [Music] awesome
dude could barely handle his elbow just getting
a little nicked what dude everybody's two straing
just stay with the one strap I can't I can't ride
out what are you doing what are you doing don't
suum to the peer pressure what are you doing
you're supposed to use two straps strap is
come to the pure pressure the two St I love that
so much those are nerds Dungeons and Dragons I
don't know I love it nerds are too strapping
the cool they look cool she's a one strapper
I'm so confused right now you find the girl
here Bri LS oh my God she's in this Captain
Captain Marvel what oh my god um okay hey Dave
Franco love him whoa is that your car yeah what's
that thing at 10 miles to the gallon n try like
s what about you biod diesel dog we try to ride
bikes when we can Global crisis and what not
Noble hey hey y'all shut the hell up trying to
study he's trying look at the nerd they're
like the cool call nerd man I'm sorry what
oh what turn that gay ass music off you punch me
because I'm gay what no I don't think he's adapted
to the times nope you're way off buddy happen to
turn out to be gay afterwards I was gay when you
punched me it might have been homophobic not
to punch you just because you were gay right
you punched a little gay black kid in the face
is that Jake Johnson girl guy you guys cross my
line again and you walk into this office I'm GNA
expel you which one of you is Doug do they not
know they probably no dude I'm Brad okay good so
that means your name is Doug son oh my God guys
oh they really failed on their prep work funny
I wouldn't have taken you for the brainy type I
would but you as a drama geek far less surprising
that's the easiest oh my God they get the separate
class you go to my classes and I'm going to go
to yours okay now chemistry is the one with the
shapes and [__] right it doesn't really matter
if they fill out the they're not there to stud
they're only there for like a minimum amount of
time right what's really sad about that kid he
was talented if he wasn't talented it would be
less sad that's not I meant I was just pussing
your balls good I remember one time doing cocaine
with Willie Nelson's horse you're talking about
this in a high school class this is awesome this
is the coolest teacher a buddy of mine really
wants it who who would he call it's not so hard
to find [Music] the oh oh my favorite molecule is
water I'd marry it unless it was my daughter it
solid form floats on its liquid form which makes
it far outside the norm givey Schmid H2O this H2
H2O H2 I'm with you buddy H2 I'd say chlorophyll
more like borophyll what is your name Brad Brad
wow look at you Brad hey you remember just name
this time uh she's really attracted to him what
is it pop Quiznos it's a quiz on the first person
who finishes gets a $10 gift certificate to
Quiznos Quiznos we don't see those around
anymore we don't but they melt the cheese in there
I know that was awesome good luck oh my god oh wow
teacher get back in your corner it's okay because
he's technically older but if he weren't te she
doesn't know that what you doing yeah because
she doesn't know that that's creepy I've got
aw I'm just the cleverest okay
yeah maybe be a tree then me try
one cooler and faster and louder and
better and less in Secure H he's a
great director yeah okay those are great
notes I'm just going to I'm going to run
outside and I'm I'm going utilize those
and I'm going to come back it's such
[__] at least they're multiple choice so he's
got a decent he's got a chance I bet you now
he'll get n because he guessed every one of them
it didn't even look you're fast not like that just
let me check you out check check my god wow uh can
I go take a dump we have this hurry back rule so
you're not back in 6 minutes I have to send you
to the principal 6 minutes oh my gosh damn she
is laying it on thick also too is 6 minutes enough
time to take a dump I don't know no that's quite a
rule ah Dave Franco is the one in charge of the
drugs do you make this stuff or look like a [__]
scientist no just sell it no I'm sorry I'm M
just how many you guys want I feel like this
is not going where we think it's going like it's
too easy maybe you're a narc you know who calls
people NCS narcs narc narcs call people Nars
and you call us Nars and that's kind of call
each other time for this [__] you guys want
to do this or not I'm not selling to two guys
who just showed up with 30 days left in school if
if he's really a dealer too take an hour get the
out drugs right here put in your moue and uh there
you go that's it is it just a cookie you got to P
the trigger you got to P the trigger oh God we got
to throw up just think of something gross think of
something gross you [__] think of something
okay your grandma's and there's going into
it no let's just finger each other's mouths e
yeah no you're not fingering my mouth do you
want to die okay fine let's go come on come
on you got to go deep and quick gross this is
so dumb it's so dumb just stick it in I don't
know I've never done this before stick it in
go oh my God gross come on guys you got to
reach for the uula and then it goes out yeah
it's sometimes I have to do that when I'm nauseous
but I don't have another individual do it for me
I don't think I want another individual there to
try to do it you guys are late now I'm going to
have to take you to the principal's office take
come on Doug McQuade you got a lot of something
special going on there young man that's a what
the hell was that damn it son don't ever raise
your hand to me like that again all right I
consider that a threat I'm Doug mcade you're
the new kid who's All County and track the track
star and his Brad are the drugs taking hit yeah
right yeah
okay oh damn here's a deal my track team is
full of physically incapable rejects I mean
if I wasn't the coach I'd be laughing my ass
off at how [__] they are oh God incapable
rejects I need you I've never had tripped
out before so it's crazy no I would not
want to hallucinate 4x400 at today's
track meet you do that and I'll sign
this pass guys don't make me take you to the
principal's office do we have a deal yes nice
a put your tongue back in your
mouth e your mouth and close it
stop it actually that's not bad
e these teachers I was going to
say these are some of the weirdest
teachers yeah are you guys on drugs
definitely not on drugs one particle of
onum has a nuclear reaction with a flux
capacitor carry the two chain did he just
get smart you know you got to take drugs to
be smart yeah okay [__] you science that's
great I've got a CR I'm just the cleverest F
was ever my fortune damn he remember those
lines really well i' got a crow not bad not
[Music]
bad keep it going keep it going that was so
tight no no no keep it going keep it [Music]
going oh my God oh God what you
going don't throw the Baton you that's literally
me anytime it ask me to run the mile in high
school that was brilliant yeah like how has he not
been thrown out yet both of them they're clearly
on drugs oh no stop come here give her don't make
dude that was awesome how you sabotaged that track
me man organized Sports were so fasion makes me
sick so you're out right he's getting cool you
should have just taken drugs the first time in
high school it would have been so much cooler
I really should have been on drugs the entire
time I was in high school probably would have
been more fun lead dealer Eric Molson he's getting
into Berkeley early ad Mish who put this together
are you artistic it is Artistic sir [Laughter]
because cut the [__] I want to know who's the
supply we don't know that's why there's a question
mark on his face oh I think it's the gym teacher
oh cuz he wasn't reacting to anything that they
were doing I don't know why I think it's him you
might be right you two standing around finger
popping each other's [__] we're not finger
popping each other's ass house well he's like
put your tongue back in your mouth and all that
that's why it just feel like he was protecting
his investment right I mean we also so when he
raised his hand he got really defensive like okay
I think you might be right and me thinking back on
these teachers are very nefarious yes what are
you doing in here I'm here to to study I know
everything really what's a coent bond [__] you
man I don't need to tell you I I wasn't trying to
be rude sorry I love that kid he's so nice yeah
what are you doing with all those phones anyway
crack and jail break kids phones uh try and save
for college I can't install a spyware to remotely
monitor calls wait you can't do it no I can't is
he being sarcastic absolutely we just have to do
something wildly irresponsible to earn their trust
you saying we should throw a party and then Molly
will invite Eric and that'll be the quickest way
for me to bro down with her you get in with the
nerd kids and see what's going on over there sure
his parents will be totally cool with him having a
party there I just call him cuz we're co-staring
this play together and hello M get off the
phone I love you honey douge Doug
Douglas so serious right now that's
such a relatable thing actually I'm
having a party this is so you and
Eric and Warrior whatever posting
on Facebook okay yeah yeah oh my
God all right I'll see you SCH here great
person oh byebye bye bye what the [__]
you how are we going to buy
alcohol dude I don't have a fake
idea huh they they couldn't call mcloven got
ice cream in there that's awesome that's cool
I've never had a punch where they put ice cream
in it we need to do that some it tastes like we
have to do it pound what is this movie pound of
marijuana best party ever Bingo who invited you
guys love it I did we love them heck yeah do
we have enough chips is this playlist too like
Dancy feels too D it's pretty Dancy it's so
nerve-wracking having a party at your house
cuz the biggest fear is like what's getting
destroyed yeah and and what are people going
through oh he just jacked his phone
yeah see aside the this thing that's a great
line yeah this is my parents bedroom oh no
are they going in oh there's the nudity wow you
never know if you might run into that at a party
I guess not thank you for the hospitality but
we got to get going you know how it is yeah is
it ready or not read this please wait extracting
data from [__] off it's a bust no you can just
delay him come on turn on a better song who the
hell is this yeah who's this guy partying with
some new stuff want to know you hook up some me
my boys to get in on it got other commitments
on that front so take five take five let me
get this I got this is he going to just punch
him let's do it man man come on what's your
real okay what do I do hit him oh damn oh no
no use your words
your [__] my [__]
this all right oh [__] yeah you did
it that was a good distraction
yeah oh perfect right in the
pocket what when did I get stabbed that's awesome
yeah that's great the adrenaline
was running so deep he didn't
know hope when I get stabbed I'm like
that's awesome yeah blow it out blow
oh go all right all right at least it's
an antiseptic okay oh my God these kids
are like this nerd is getting getting
some action this is the coolest part
oh no they're passing around the drugs oh
everybody's getting going to get wild it's
not good though that mean some kid could
something could happen at the party die
uhoh get my I said out the part over
she have a stick in her hand I love
it that's great all how you feel about making a
little extra money whatever it is I'm in yes now
we're in I can't sell all this [__] on my own
but I only bring in people I like I introduce you
to my hookup how's that sound let's do it no
you hey thank you again for the party man you
you oh he's jealous yep dude this is part the
tables have turned it's part of the plan but
like he thought he'd be like there was no way he
could get cool what kind of a sick animal draws
an ejaculating into an 8-year-old's mouth like
an airplane throwing up you think I don't know
that balls I know all about balls I Robert Dy Jr
before he got sober when he was really [__] up
I took Eric's phone and I had Zach put his
monitoring device in it I don't know if that
was a good idea this is like the smartest
move I've ever pulled so I'm sorry what are
you getting mad at me for is he getting too deep
he's getting emotionally compromised I feel like
he wants to stay in high school longer and not
figure it out because he finally now knows how
it is to be cool yeah that's a that's a good
point right he's like is getting emotionally
compromised at the situation totally password
kneel before Zod you may enter kneel before
Zod that's amazing do you understand the
reference to Superman 2 oh cool KN before
zard I don't know I don't believe in possession
ja feel ja feel definitely feel yeah Smitty oh
no I'll be right don't blow your cover she's
gonna oh no go to her and send her out and be
like that's my crazy grandma I have got to call
Annie she is going to die sh shut shut your [__]
mouth shut your [__] mouth I will straight
up punch you in the face if you not [Laughter]
your oh who she's TR to grab my J she was
like oh my God I have arthritis hurts my
hand I need to grab a handful of that I
was like get the [__] off wow I have
arthritis what a possessively sick woman
and I need to grab a handful of why would
she try doing that with a teenage young man
and also she has arthritis it's going to be
really hard to hold on to that dick
that's disgusting that you would do
[Music] that at least he sticks to his
environmentalism yeah sings it in a song
Ready notore oh he's going to listen into his
phone and Jonah Hill's going to say something
bad about his partner a long time what are
you doing I heard something I just just want
to make sure that you and Eric are going to be
careful with it would just suck if something
bad happened cuz I already lost my dad to act
together see Neil before thought that's Terren
stamp okay we going to take the prom there's
no one to go prom with us pull up in a white
stallion of a limo you got fine ass Honeys with
you you're dressed to the nines with your best
buds dubs fly out behind you slow motion he
never got to go to prom and he's going to get
to go with his best buddies or he could take that
teacher that really likes him right oh God I hope
not isn't aren't you and Eric wouldn't you and
Eric go together not that I know of ask her oh
he's got PTSD but this is a different situation
I know but it's come on maybe oh my God are you
okay I am that is the actual sound of joking
I was wondering if you uh say it come on maybe
you want to go with me to prom you want to go to
Me Maybe with me to prom Yes W we made it good
for you Doug oh are they going to kiss somebody's
going to interrupt of course it's the movie trible
there man just put it what what putting it there
maybe because he's a rule follower and is like
you're not allowed to right sleep with or like
students and your brother aren't related right
cuz you look totally different he's adopted
we all suspect from a very lame family yeah
I know it you called that yeah tools he hangs
out you know how Tom Cruz is always pissed off
at Rainman that's like my life oh boy do you
understand that reference yeah it's it's an old
school one and it's calling him yeah that's not
that's not cool yeah you either find a supplier
or I'm going jump your asses off Street I heard
Eric talking on the phone yesterday about meeting
up with a stuffed Piñata is that a call for sex
that was an email he was about to click before
Brie Larson walked in on him yeah it said pinata
yeah how do I look ravishing is it too sexy of
an outfit yeah yeah definitely definitely I'm so
happy that I met you you're like the only guy that
I can really trust yeah boy that's going to suck
for her when she finds out known as Sal Peter God
oh the pinata oh that's where the drugs are
coming in I need to borrow you now it's not a
good time it's a really good time cuz my pinata
is killing me is that good for a thing I have a
feeling there's nothing in it but we'll see feel
like it's got to be right there's got to okay oh
they're going to go in and Chase oh no oh God
you're going to miss the play you shouldn't
have taken that part when he's under cover what no
oh cuz they have so many violations because they
keep parking in handicap why are they doing that
driver's car school bus I'm driving no you're not
I never get to drive oh are they taking the Ed
car oh I wanted them to take the school bus go
guys hey wait guys you're not on the list hey
guys wait who cares like it's a crap car and a
crap job anyways I don't give a shnit shnit it's
a new word Andrew Flash Gordon just made up are
these the biker they wanted to arest him for
the marijuana before those are the guys in the
park that's just too crazy we think in that
thing oh it has to be in there or maybe they
just want to play with a pinata they're taking
to a kid's barbecue over the weekend you sure
wor I see guys we definitely got to follow
him and find out though there is no way he's
making it back to the play no no just pretend
like you're sucking my why am I automatically
you that's a very inconspicuous
vehicle a student driver take your
foot off the brake no take your foot off The Brak
no guys you're okay now we've
done it you not driving mother
get I mean at least then you could just be
like sorry student driver easy
easy easy my God [Music] whoa
oh I know but the whole point was to follow them
oh god well now they're going to get chased after
yeah but they need to follow them to their place
it's two people back there sh oh no traffic oh
God oh [__] what's wrong with you run I can't
I'm wearing tights I got skinny chees on the
same get out the car douche to call here jackass
oh my God yeah all right sorry buddy hope somebody
picks you up later there's golf balls in this
what am I supposed to do with this no that's
awesome oh that's great nice hit woow uhoh
[Music] okay oh damn big boom coming what
happened I don't know it just didn't explode
who do you guys think you're in a movie
[Music] mhm right there no testing
yes you are you're texed no I'm
not fair I'll be there fairly I'm driving
why you always drip over the like that did
you say fairly like a fairy fairy like well like
Tinker Bell right you are fine and [__] don't
worry oh my God that was a very attractive
woman not going to lie I'm loving all these
vehicles they're getting oh they're in a a
Volkswagen I love that good old bug bug 1963
bug and bright orange was my first vehicle
you're [Music] welcome oh no that's got to
oh ow that's got to hurt dude he just got ran
over by an 18wheeler oh my God Windows what is
it not going to explode again no there's fire
right next to it cuz the bike right it's going
against action movie tropes I love it I love
it the hell oh my God she had a gun okay hey
girl oh oh [Music]
[Music] boyi sounded like the willhelm screen
oh no not the chickens not the chickens why
did that one have to blow up seriously come on
movie I don't know how long this case is going
to last and Eric's going to get into Berkeley and
honestly I can get in too who knows I could ride
this thing out I could be a doctor or something
have you lost your mind this is not real buddy
I could be a doctor boys squads come quickly
hey wor I'm here uh I know I missed uh first
few scenes I want to thank give it up to uh oh
my goodness we just R right into this thing huh
this is my twin
together it's okay I'll make
it up to you and uh let's
fly I guess I should do something I should
probably not just stand here watching I should
take action best friend ever this is definitely
more entertaining than not you don't yeah I'm
sorry I don't want to talk to you ever again
she's definitely not going to prom now you stupid
[Applause] idiot come come damn he's strong to
withstand a rock stop stop it you're expelled
both of you are expelled and that's the
end of act two Bravo that was amazing I
want to know how long they rehears that yeah
beautifully choreographed is that it you're
not going to you're not going to scream
at us nope I'm going just fire you oh I
mean the fact that these guys got through
three cases and they haven't even finished
one kind of says something you know what's
crazy to me is that I think that I actually
thought that we were brothers I would have
taken a bullet for you a get in now both of
you is this the reveal of the dealer yeah is
he going to be like are these the two guys
you saw or something the messed up [__]
went down yesterday yeah after we made the
exchange our potential business partners got
followed by some cops okay a lot of things have
made me wonder about you the taste of Music
fact that you look like a 40-year-old man I
realized there's no way you guys could
be cops no way no way I got this deal
going down the supplier is going to be there I
need people I can trust hey come on okay right
over here we're going to shoot these bottles
we're going to practice okay oh God don't be
good definitely not cops that was actually really
awesome beginner's luck we played a lot of Area
51 in Time Crisis we're good any predictions
on the dealer I'm still going to stick with
my original I do like your guess I'm just going
to stick with the gym the gym [Music] teacher I
mean cuz I got to assume it's someone we've
seen before they're not just going to give
us someone random and I don't know who else it
could be besides him doing our time chores right
now if you stay in this house you have time
for [Music] chores yes what if it's like the
Nerds I don't think it is cuz they don't
but what if they're just like we sell it
but we don't do them the nerd the Nerds that
he's gotten to be friend I don't think it is
I don't know man that definitely be a Twist
if it was the Nerds I will say I would not
have seen that coming in anyway there a there's
actually an emotional core to this film I mean
it's not like deep or anything but there's
an emotional core yeah their chemistry is
great oh they're they're really good together
you can really feel will you go to prom with
me that's sweet go oh they both missed their
prom their first prom are we really going to
take down a whole drug operation by ourselves
I got some contacts that'll help us the Nerds
yeah if it's the Nerds I don't know if they would
let them help them get into prom right no I think
it was a bad that's like all bad what I guessed I
think it's totally wrong um that is great that's
great I love that nice oh my God that's the lady
from that's awwesome that's the worker lady that
was in that's friends with them as cops she
was constantly being questioned cuz she's a
you need to leave need to leave need to get out
of here right now making a lot of hand gestures
okay my name is not Doug it's Schmidt and I'm
a cop what this is not the time to display this
information pay no attention to the couple
kissing in the background it is him you're
all right beautiful bread I just didn't know
who else it would be no yeah it's a great yeah
of course he loves his Doritos I do agree with
the finger and the well yeah he was just trying
to hide that's what told me he was trying to make
like it was obvious to him they were on drugs and
he even said it and he's like Noe put put your
tongue back that back in there so nobody knows
oh no oh they're going to know who they are y
damn it oh boy here in trouble now of all the
guys yeah what you having a party now who these
two mother oh crap hey kid come here you you look
familiar I was in a a french fry commercial when
I was a kid do I look like I eat french fries I
don't know you look like you're in great shape
but maybe you have like one cheet like a carb
car blow [Laughter] out you look like you're
a yeah theme song's like come to Andrew's
fren I love it that's my song who wants a
piece dog or whatever your name is you lied
to me oh phase five is where you get overly
honest right I know these too your boys are
cops you are outgunned we party together man you
brought us Taco Bell you made me this friendship
bracelet well he's not really your friend he was
pretending the whole time Taco Bell bring somebody
Taco Bell is like giving a blood sacrifice
yo don't hit de Franco I know these guys were
C there you are drop your guns or I'll spray
your brains all over the room drop the guns or
she's dead she looks dead already what shoot yeah
I can hear her breathing she just passed out from
the drugs we're good dude it's just like the
image with the guy and the woman and the woman
like boom boom boom between this is his character
Arc to hit the the moving Target let's let's just
relax and we can all leave here as friends yeah
let's do that you all boys are stup we're going
to die God damn it he's undercover to on your
knees Johnny Depp Johnny Jeff Johnny de oh my
goodness little dweebs just r a 5-year
investigation we had no idea hey the
original crew you play saxophone in my sister's
wedding man T too hey that's the best twist ever
Metro Police Jump Street division that's
funny because we were actually Jump Street
what what what oh
whoa oh no not the original crew here take
the money all right we're getting out of
here you could him just behind his head not
aiming anywhere best cop ever sometimes I was
a jerk we were undercover I just I didn't
feel good about myself that's it's like
basically what they would say to each other the
tight pants was just so that people would think
I'm cool he called him Doug they have the
same names as their undercover names that
I ever needed was my best friend let's do this
let's make a baby what are you talking I don't
know try close [Music] sorry yes get your
slow-mo action shot yeah you oh yeah whoa
cool he's gonna throw it oh God
so that would actually really
hurt [Music] nice shot that was crazy you killed a
guy hey they threw up finally right it's
the song at every graduation right yeah
I just remember this song from Scary
Movie too [Music] hey h that's like
perfect [Music] look who I did
that was that was beautifully
perfect that was great perfect slide
Perfect Landing come hang out with me
back give me my money oh damn I'm living my dream
of standing in a LMO oh my God what what K you
kill you no oh my God oh my gosh girl you got to
relax how drunk is she how how do you not see the
gunshots hear the gunshots I'm to oh my god oh
you had to go you you wouldn't lay off it that
well that's probably the safer thing too you
are too aggressive you still got those shotgun
shells yeah pop Quiznos now they'll finally have
he going to do what he learned from chemistry yeah
that would be a coent Bond brother that's coent
Bond see I knew that was going to come back to
play that makes them stick together are you saying
we're coent bonds yes and that you did call that
one [Music] too but it's going to be delayed
what's this tequila I don't know it's it was
supposed to explode using that big old brain love
it where' you learn how to do that man chemistry
chemistry [__] it's a good thing they actually
switched yes and thank goodness for your nerd
friends who actually taught you a lot about that
don't you pull that armor nope oh come on let's
go this is your test he no no no I said no oh my
gosh I didn't mean to shoot you I meant to shoot
him are you Al buddy okay took a pull for me man
do you have a vest on yeah but he still got in the
shoulder the vest doesn't cover the shoulder
that's skin head shot right in the eye right
between the eyes we want I know but in the in the
poster he got him in both the eyes you peaked in
high school mother Ah that's a good line oh
oh yeah oh yikes that reminds me of Robocop
oh boy yikes you are under arrest anything you
said can and will be us that's a great call back
yes yes Miranda writes B that's a great great
call back look I'm sorry I called you Rainman
I know I didn't say you were but you're smart
that's a compliment he's smart and he won an
Oscar yeah hey that was a jump and it was
on the street they just got to do it 20
more times yeah that's not funny is that
it what it's on the ground no oh my God
no no no [Music] no no I hated it gross I'm
really sorry I know you wanted a guy to trust
and I wanted to be that person so badly
you deserve a guy who who Who's good and
who doesn't lie to you thanks for saving my life
a put her there partner feel like she's going to
kiss him yeah okay good call felt that coming
again if she wasn't 18 I'd be creeped out yeah
on I had a feeling they were going to end up
together since you two Cowboys love to drink
booze smoke weed with kids and anything with a
big ass in jeans I'mma send you to a place where
all that [__] is allowed oh I love Disneyland
you two sons of [__] are going to college oh
no is it going to be Berkeley though is that
the sequel I want to see that whoa that was an
awesome mening credit Miller yes that was dope
oh my God that was so fun that was a lot of fun
oh I didn't know Jonah Hill did the story that's
awesome that's like oh and these ending like these
what this these ending credits are awesome yeah
uh that was a blast I had from the past I had a
lot of fun the the chemistry between the two
of them like casting 10 Stars off the charts
because if it wasn't them two it wouldn't have
been as good with their chemistry um so good and
I love the heartfelt moments like when he when he
hears Jonah Hill speaking about like he's like a
Rainman he annoys me he's like not smart whatever
and you see like Channing Tatum right before that
being like like good job man like you made the
move you asked her to prom like he was always
really supportive of him and then that must have
been really heartbreaking right and then the way
that they come back together I mean Bravo I always
complain I would complain if this is like a funny
funny movie with lots of action if it didn't
have the heart I'd be like I'm not sold on it
it does have the heart and I thank you oh he did
do the teacher oh boy I can't imagine why was she
giving him signed she wanted him like at all oh
Mark mothers Boro the the composer that was the
composer of Thor uh Ragnarok which I I love his
score in th ref one of my favorite scores I I I
agree with everything you just said like yeah the
the comedy and the action were all there but it
was the heart and the the chemistry between the
two of them that was you know that sold me and
made me love this movie so much and it was just
so much fun uh I'm sure there was 10 obviously
we did not watch the 21 Jump Street TV show with
uh Johnny Depp and Richard Grio though that was
such a cool thing to I don't again I don't know
I mean maybe we'll see here in the creds in a
second I obviously we know that was Johnny Depp
I don't know if that was Richard GCO at the end
or who who that actor was but um that was such
a cool little uh Easter egg if you will at the
end there um because I did not see that coming
um and then also too with I assume the car and
I'm sure there were plenty other Easter eggs that
they did for people who had seen the show um but
yeah no I mean I thought it was interesting too
like cuz obviously Jonah Hill's character Schmid
I believe his name was he was you know more on the
nerdy side when he was in high school and you know
awkward and just uh wasn't cool and obviously
uh Chan Tatum excuse me uh was uh cool but not
smart and you know they had their character arcs
kind of like got infused with okay you know J
Jonah Hill got to learn how to you know well he
got to be cool when he went back to high school
all never been kiss style you know Drew Barrymore
if you will um but then he felt like what it felt
uh you know when he made fun of him it's like oh
this is what it feels like yeah like yeah it's
cool but it's more important like friendship and
Brotherhood is more important and then also two
on the flip side um I think chaining Tatum also
realized like yeah it's not like being cool isn't
like what it's all about and like using your
brain and other things like Brotherhood again
same same kind of thing like they just met in the
middle uh there's more important things out in the
world but I love that uh he got to use his brain
in such a unique way like from the chemistry class
learning and turning that into like an explo
or a bomb whatever he uh the convenient Bond
or thank you yes clearly she's much smarter than
me um but yes um that was I I really love that
touch of the film but yeah there was just a lot
more layers than I was expecting it wasn't super
not was trying to be or anything but it's also
like when what you were just saying of like him
getting smart was like let alone from the kids
that he never would have spoken to back in the
day right that was also in his flip absolutely
but also too it was about like adapting to the
times because I mean Jonah Hill even said yeah
damn if I would have just went to high school 10
years later I missed it by a decade like it's like
because I mean we saw on the first scene when they
went back when they got back to high school like
he hit the kid he's like yeah he's listening to
this game music it's like dude you're you're in
a different time you're you're in the wrong time
like maybe 10 15 years ago wrong time zone yeah
that would have been okay but like that doesn't
that doesn't work now but it was funie wouldn't
necessarily work in 2023 no way there's there's
a lot of stuff that they wouldn't wouldn't pass
if they made this film today but um yeah I mean
it it was a lot of fun I do I do like the the
flip of like you know him getting cool and him
getting smart and learning because before it
was like Channing Tatum's character was all
about like I have to act like I don't care and
if you don't care then you're cool and all he
had to do was like care a little bit and then he
realized like he could tap into everything that
he had been put in kind of in the in the back
burner which is his brains um and I I really
like the Nerds I'm like I want oh they were great
as friends they were great no I mean I I wouldn't
have expected Channing Tatum to go with that crew
but again adapting and changing to the times it
actually was perfect it Mak sense for him to be
with those crew CU he had so much fun together
yeah no they were great I I loved that crew and
then uh just again they were unique to him and he
was unique to them so I think oh Superman 2 that
was so good the Neo before Zod has the greatest P
besides have you seen Ace Ventura Pet Detective
yes but it's been ages so I will add this to my
second uh favorite password cuz my first one is
from Ace Pet Detective when he says what's the
password New England clam chout now it's going
to be Neil before Zod so I've got two passwords
now but look at him I know yes yes your phone show
yeah exactly New England wow this is long clam uh
sh my nerdy side showing my referencing nerdy side
but really really are no but um there were just so
many different great uh aspects of this film um
also to the the whole uh thing with um with the
uh with theand oh no no oh they had the Miranda
Right call back was that call back I loved yeah
I love to the idea just I mean the way they play
with fun action adventure Oh I thought they were
showing in after credit scene the idea too of just
playing with fun action adventure tropes they did
it in a couple different ways like when they were
on one of the when they were on the one of those
chases when he was in the Peter pant tights and
so they're like waiting for explosions like oh
here comes an explosion oh here comes an expion no
explosion then they're jumping over the uh what is
it the the limo like to make it look cool when
you jump over the hood of the car to get to the
front how did that look perfectly cuz that that's
that's an action adventure thing and then jumping
over the couch and Jonah Hill couldn't land
it it's just I love the way they were playing
with action adventure tropes it was just it was
hysterical like it made sense for the story but
it was hysterical at the same point uh but yeah
and then there was obviously the the story story
line that they were doing with the the drugs
and all that at first I thought that they were
going to um the first scene they had where Dave
Franco was selling them drugs I thought it was
just going to be like um he was just going to sell
it was just going to be like a normal cooking and
like oh wow this was a waste of time but that's
what I thought they were going with that I mean
obviously we knew there were drugs involved but I
thought that's where they were going at first and
then it was going to at oh he had to earn their
trust or something but I'm like all right you're
just selling this to two guys who 30 days left
in school who just showed up in your school like
you're very trustworthy sir right but uh I mean
I guess on the flip side like for his argument is
like he's just making them eat it right now he's
not letting them take it anywhere but still I was
like this is very trustworth yeah and I I like
the setup how it's is it Tarantino or an Edgar
right thing where it's like the titles pop up so
I feel like we needed them to do the drug so we
could get through the phases and see them again so
that when we would see others we're like oh yeah
they're at they're at Phase phase four or phase
five um I liked how those came up the phase one
phase two phase three it was really really fun to
see them go through that um and man just like take
me back to that party yo so I can like actually uh
be in a real high school party [__] except like
we don't break anything it just seemed fun and
I won't do any drugs but I will drink yeah but
when he gets stabed and doesn't really because
the adrenaline stabbed yeah but the adrenaline
was pumping so much for him because he was he's
never been a cool kid he's I mean he's never been
in a f well I mean he's I know he's been in police
train but he's never actually a real one yeah not
a he got he got pum pummeled over by that one
guy in the biker but he's never actually been
in a fight and just like again had his adrenaline
rushing so much well I guess you could say he had
his adrenaline rushing once when he tried asking
that one woman to prom in the first scene of the
film um but clearly you could tell she was uh
very disinterested uh but again he didn't have
a knife in the back of his uh or in his back
or whatever that yeah so um but I just I love
everyone's reaction to it and then they just
poured alcohol on the wound it's like go back
to partying and like oh my God yeah it's a party
I would love to attend so good and I loved when
they finally when he asked him to go to prom I was
like yes this movie The Writing I love the story
and the writing I thought it was just like it was
really really good uh I five five out of five man
for the writing cuz it made me laugh Oh I thought
you about to say five out of 10 I was like I love
the writing five out of 10 five out of five 10 out
of 10 for the writing cuz I I really loved it I
thought it was really really funny I thought the
the pacing the tone was great and also just like
the the pacing of the editing even though they
didn't use um like any crazy techniques of shots
I mean most of it was just basic setup of like a
master and a and a mid shot and a closeup right
for a lot of times when he's there with a cop and
whatnot they got more creative when when they're
in the action but a lot of that even was just
like slow-mo like it's not like you were doing
anything crazy cinematically and this movie it
didn't even like cross my mind that I was like oh
this is just like basic setups it it is that with
some other playful stuff because the script in the
story and also the chemistry with the actors you
don't need it like this is just it's great and
even though the the film was paced really like
I it was kind of a fanatic pce but it was still
paced really well but I still like that they took
their time progressing the two of them with their
Brotherhood it never felt rushed it always felt
organic to me like by the time that they there
was a mutual like understanding and Brotherhood
yeah it felt earned it didn't feel like wow that
was really quick I mean I'm still glad that
they ended up to like you know having a mutual
understanding and their brothers and all that or
their great friends Partners whatever you want
to say but like yeah but that happened so quickly
like I don't buy no they really took their time in
this film and like it was close to the end of the
film but again it was it was really well earned
and I bought it and like everything they had been
through throughout the film everything they had
done for each other I really did buy that he would
jump even though he he did have a bulletproof vest
on him it didn't matter like there's still parts
of your body that are still exposed you still got
your face too that could get hit I really do buy
that he would jump in front of a bullet for him
you know that was that was hard and I loved how
the how the climax of their fight was actually
during the Peter Pan play and The Way They Carried
that out of course it has to come out of like I
heard what you called me and like you know he was
just calling him your sish your whatever they were
saying it was like that big fight happened on a
stage in front of a bunch of people I liked how
that all came out and I do agree the ending was
totally earin because they took their time it's
great I I love I really like this movie I thought
it was a blaster Ro so I don't know I'm going to
go like eight eight and a half out of 10 cuz I'm
just like what a what a blast this was okay we
got to be like Jonah Hill and Channing Tatum on
this I'm going to go eight and a half out of 10
this look at us we did it any last words before
we get out of here just uh I really enjoy this
I think you said it best uh the the action was
great it was fun uh the comedy it was hysterical
but it had the heart and the chemistry between
the two of them was fantastic I uh I can't think
of a better Duo for this um I'm always going to be
curious even though it's never it probably never
going to happen um cuz they had talked about for a
long time with Sony uh they wanted to do a team up
of Men In Black and 21 drum Street yeah oh what
why didn't they do that I don't know that would
have worked um I mean I still would have seen me
after this movie I mean like if they yeah I I'm
interested to see the sequels of this specifically
I want to see 22 Jump Street but I mean I'm just
cuz I remember when they were talking about
21 Jump Street black but I'm curious how that
would have worked yeah I mean if you have a good
story it's a good story but that's an interesting
pairing of dumla that I never would have thought
of well I guess we'll see interest well it's not
it's most likely I it was talked about years
and years and years ago but uh I don't know if
that's ever going to happen whatever I think
the bigger UPS y all should make it that's
all for us we love you so much don't forget to
leave a like leave a comment tell us how cool we
are because we love so much not and we will see
you very very soon on the next one [Music] bye